pero no
[Música]
bienvenidos a nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casa blanca en la recta
final para las elecciones esto es lo que
usted necesita saber y empecemos por la
imagen de la semana
donald trump y yo white en debatieron
por fin en el último cara a cara en
nashville después de la cancelación del
segundo debate por el diagnóstico
positivo por kobe 19 del presidente y de
que un primero en el que más que un
intercambio de ideas hubo un intercambio
de insultos e interrupciones a pesar de
que las acusaciones se mantuvieron este
encuentro fue más civilizado como se
esperaba el ex vicepresidente demócrata
arremetió contra la gestión de el
coronavirus por parte de champ
responsabilizándolo de las más de
220.000 muertes registradas en eeuu
200.000 estadounidenses muertos si se
quedan con algo de esta noche escuchen
esto es cualquiera que sea responsable
por no haber tomado el control por decir
no acepto la responsabilidad
cualquiera que sea responsable por
tantas muertes no debería seguir siendo
presidente de eeuu de américa
estamos aprendiendo a vivir con él no
tenemos opción no podemos encerrarnos en
un sótano como hace joe él tiene la
capacidad de quedarse
cerrado no sé obviamente él ha hecho
mucho dinero en alguna parte le gusta
vivir en su sótano pero la gente no
puede hacer eso
[Música]
vamos a washington para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal diana castañeda y
ahora vimos en este debate a un trompo
un poco más moderado este lo ayuda o lo
perjudica
bueno básicamente esta era la última
oportunidad que tenía el presidente de
donaldson para tratar de disminuir el
sin margen esa ventaja que le lleva joe
biden con un porcentaje de 7 a 10 puntos
dependiendo las encuestas a nivel
nacional y definitivamente le ayuda a
tener digamos un lenguaje un poco más
moderado en este último debate aunque
las encuestas al día de hoy muestran o
dan como ganador del debate al joe biden
hay que ver y esto se podrá conocer
digamos en las siguientes semanas cuando
se den nuevos sondeos de favorabilidad
si el presidente realmente logró
convencer a algunos de sus seguidores o
algunos de los votantes indecisos de
sumarse a las filas del partido
republicano para las próximas elecciones
y si como dices vaivén tiene la
delantera en las 50 encuestas de
intención de voto y teniendo en cuenta
que hay una cifra récord de voto
anticipado como ayuda entonces este
debate a bailén por su parte
bueno está muy claro hay más de 46
millones de personas que ya han votado
en los eeuu este es un récord en
comparación a las elecciones anteriores
y digamos que la mayoría de personas que
han votado anticipadamente pues ya han
tomado su decisión y muchos en esta
semana y en la semana que queda de estos
votantes indecisos podrían también tomar
su decisión y esto es lo que digamos
busca bailén y llevar a cabo digamos una
campaña más agresiva para convertir a
estos votantes también a muchos votantes
jóvenes que aún no les convence ninguno
de los dos candidatos y sobre todo
porque se estima que cerca de un 15% de
personas que lleguen a las urnas el día
de las elecciones no sabrán por quién
votar hasta que lleguen frente a la
balota y tomen la decisión así que
todavía queda tiempo y estará una
oportunidad para bailén de terminar de
mostrar su plataforma y digamos
básicamente demostrar porque debería ser
elegido como presidente de los estados
donde ellos
diana y volvamos sobre este punto del
voto anticipado o en ausencia explícanos
en qué consiste y qué significan estas
cifras récord que ya estamos viendo
bueno este voto anticipado se digamos
extendido y facilitado en muchos estados
sobre todo en estados que tienen
gobernadores demócratas que han digamos
facilitado más lugares de votación al
extendido los horarios porque durante la
pandemia el gran temor es que la gente
no se movilizará a las urnas y también
porque temen que el día de las
elecciones se puedan registrar largas
filas y que la gente por temor al
contagio de kobe no asista a las
votaciones pero hasta el momento todo ha
mostrado lo contrario a pesar de muchos
intentos de gobernadores republicanos
para obstaculizar este derecho por
ejemplo en el estado de texas donde por
varias locaciones que incluso tienen
hasta 4 millones de personas el
gobernador estableció solo un punto de
votación lo cual afecta claramente este
derecho a los votantes a ejercer no su
voz alzar su voz y ejercer este derecho
al voto bueno es el análisis de diana
castañeda corresponsal de france 24 en
washington gracias por acompañarnos en
esta emisión de nuestros
especial de aquí américa camino a la
casa blanca recuerden que pueden
seguirme en las redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho del coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]